>>Teacher: Guys, I know-- just
take a deep breath, you guys.
Just give us a few minutes, okay?
Justin, could you stop please?
Okay. Ladies and gentlemen..
>>Narrator: Having trouble
managing your classroom?
Here are some of our
favorite tricks of the trade.
>>Filipe: Are you going to play?
Okay.
>>Narrator: Kindergarten teacher,
Filipe Lara, uses sign language
to answer individual questions
while maintaining focus
on the class lesson.
>>Felipe: Well when
they ask me a question,
then I'll either answer
"Yes," or "No."
It helps me figure out--
it's less interruptive.
And then if I see a kid in
the back and I go like this
and he only sees me, then no one else
is going to ask me to have a drink
of water or go to the bathroom
because they don't
know what he asked.
So when they ask, it's
less interruptive,
and there's no break
in the instruction.
So that's-- all my kids know
to give me a sign language
when they have a question, or
if I'm working with an adult,
or if they want water, or to go to
the bathroom, so that's what that is.
>>Narrator: Share one of your tricks
with fellow teachers on Edutopia.